spider-man into the spider-verse is one
of the most innovative films you will
ever see and I'm not just saying that
because the guys to my right who he is
playing the role of Peter Parker and
spider-man it was nominated for the Best
Motion Picture animated Golden Globe
just today and Jake Johnson is here in
studio good to see you sir good to see
you sir
you Congrats on this movie in advance
thanks man I'm really excited about it
I'm excited for people to see this one
so before we get into the the sports
talk John and will sorry cycle back as
well to this film for the radio audience
adjusted not here we our conversation we
had this is an animated film
yes it's an animated film it's the
introduction of Miles Morales who is a
African American Puerto Rican spider-man
this is the movie he learns to become
spider-man Peter Parker as we know him
in this universe is the mr. Miyagi to
his karate kid' nice
Nixon analogy yeah thank you new cages
in this movie he's great he's great I
mean it was one of those when I when he
first showed up again I saw this last
night and I'm a huge hero thank you for
coming on the show a be you coming on
the show allowed me to get a link to the
movie last kid zarnow showing up in
school today bragging that they saw the
new spider-man movies that's a huge dad
point for me for sure
huge dad points for me but my wife and I
were like whose voice is that
and we looked with Nick Cage he's come
on yeah I heard a funny story one of the
writers and directors Rodney Rothman
during NIC cages record they just found
all funny 1930s lines and we just
pitched lines from him from the 1930s he
plays the 30s film knew our guy right
the film noir yeah and so NIC cages
record was just seen a line from the 30s
like you know those daggers swing baby
girl you're saying it may be like thanks
Nick how about this one like what a
record I wanted you could just put
anything in front of him right there I
actually asked to be involved because I
got to record with shamekh who plays
miles and I got record or some of the
others but I asked if I could go to
Vegas on my own dime just to record with
Nick Cage Vegas yeah well that's where
he is he has not left Las Vegas is when
he's Nick Cage you go to
and the directors and producers know
mean they're like no you're not coming
in a cage for card we don't need you
well I mean that's what we call a plum
assignment you imagine what that
recording studio is all about that's not
like the same one I'm in I'm in a
regular box he's in like a gold box it's
probably in his basement with Mike
Tyson's Tigers but it's great you know
Jake as you point out um you know
there's all different characters from I
guess the spider-man mover that you see
different takes on it and in terms of
the first female yeah in this you know
I've got two daughters and so I've been
recording this for the last two and a
half years it's been a really long job
and when I first told him I sold most
playing spider-man we would play
superheroes and they would call
themselves Spider Man girl mm-hmm and I
was like that's kind of sad and I was
like a white guy with representation
I've always had all the characters
mm-hmm so I'm like oh wow you don't have
to be spider-man girl you can actually
just be spider Glen and she kicks butt
and she's cool and she's a drummer I got
to tell you my five year old girl my
five year old daughter sat up the entire
time was locked in and blurted out
towards India I want to be spider-gwen
and then she wants to be inspired when
for for Halloween she wants the costume
so she saw okay yeah it is she saw a a
somebody who's like her yeah who's
really cool well I mean and she does
have those moves already down pat it's a
problem it's a problem trying to
socialize her into society right but for
guys like us older white guys we still
have Peter Parker Joe so we're still in
this movie so it's one of those movies
that it's just you know it's really fun
I stand behind the message and it but
it's also shamekh reminds me when I get
to 40 year old guy about it he's like
yeah it's not about the message it's
just a really funny movie and I'm like
yeah it is it's actually just a really
good movie but I also believe in it so
it's a win-win for me
in theaters December 14th spider-man
into the spider-verse here on the Rich
Eisen show at the man who plays Peter
Parker and spider-man Jake Johnson all
right Jake as a lifelong Bears fan yeah
first time I ever met you
was when I was doing this show as a
podcast up at the NFL Network and you
showed up and you showed up in your
Ditka your Ditka sweater yeah literally
from me from back in the day okay so
what can you compute what this team
looks like right now well you know it's
the 2008 the world has changed is 2018
and it's so of the Chicago Bears
apparently and I love everything about
it I love our offense I love the team
unity obviously I love our defense I
think Mac is a perfect bear and I didn't
realize it when he was in Oakland but he
fits our DNA
now so he's a team guy he's a hard
worker he's not a big ego guy but he's
dominant so he didn't come in and we're
not dealing with a big attitude and a
big ego who sees himself bigger than the
team but puts up numbers he's one of
those guys from everything I've read and
seen he's working hard he's making other
people better he's part of the unit he
cares about the offense so I'm like lot
first of all Gruden come on buddy
he's calling out bud he coughed him up
to you Cooper I'm like what's the I
understand getting draft picks and
saving money but eventually you got to
start winning game I know some Pat's
some point you gotta hit the win it now
button yeah and also with the draft
you're getting fun you get bow so let's
say you get number one I still take Mac
over them you gotta pay bow say no I
know at some point and and the thing
that I do like about what the Bears are
doing right now and it's gonna be I
think the entirety of the back the
entire backdrop to the Sunday night game
yes for sure he's with the Rams coming
in with their young quarterback that
they hooked up to a dynamic play calling
schemer with a game wrecker on the
defensive line at team speed everywhere
else I mean I just described the Rams to
you but that's also their model yeah
there's the Bears are in that model
what's going on but we also our running
game
I mean don't sleep on Howard when it
gets really cold he hasn't had a great
year yet right he's an unbelievable
running back he's at a he's a top-ten
guy so when it gets cold we still do
have him I got a question for you yes
Jake Jones are you a believer in what
naggy the Bears we had
on the show what about six weeks ago a
delight absol seems like a delight to
talk to ya
Brockman and I as follicly challenged
guys the only thing we don't understand
about Negi is that he wears a visor
which only accentuates the dome it
doesn't protect the dome you got to
figure out the headphones there's always
a will to what the Hat he's got on yeah
there's something there's just a little
but other than that yes your bet that's
those are high those are high rent
problems yeah you know what I'm saying
but in this again right now for the NFL
to win this year and to win for the next
five years yeah you need to have what
the Bears have which is which is what I
just described to you with team speed
everywhere where prior to the snap the
defense is wondering how am I gonna
cover all these fast guys come out of
the backfield and out wide and got a
slot and then post snap the scheme is
not what you're expired so pre-snap post
snap is a problem yes the movement pre
snaps a problem watch those linebackers
like getting confused as defense you
know as long as Vic Fangio you can hold
on to him I think every they're coming
for him oh I know you may have the three
deal but somebody comes knocking on the
door at work actually do we you know the
whole thing I never understand is the
permission yeah so he's got a three year
contract yeah so let's say the Packers
say we're looking for a head coach we
want fake vengeance well a fear of the
pack if you're the if the Packers come
knockin the Bears that the Bears were
like he's knocking elsewhere these Ryan
pace allowed to say we're not granting
that interview like how did that work I
do believe he's allowed to say we're not
unless Harmon if it's fir if it's for a
promotion right he cannot deny that so
head coach he could go there I do
believe so but if it's for defensive
coordinator you could say so bouncing
bouncing okay yeah but a promotion no
matter what your contract says you can
jump
I think the pattern and and if the
Packers to continue on in this
conversation Jake Johnson who's playing
spider-man to the spider versus a Peter
Parker here on the Rich Eisen show we
were talking about who's the best coach
for the Packers and Aaron Rodgers nine
forward I think Aaron Rodgers thinks he
would be his own best coach well that's
a perfect bears response to that
question but it's having a defensive guy
come in say I'm taking care of that side
of the ball you Terry
and maybe Joe Philbin who's you know
taking over as the coach there you can't
you take care of the offense I'm gonna
make sure your three touchdowns a game
stands up right more often than not like
that might be the right one so obviously
Fangio could be that guy but with Fangio
and this defense and Khalil Mack be in
there and Eddie Jackson being a
Defensive Player of the Year candidate
and role Quan Smith I mean you can go on
and on you know uh Cohen you know a team
hex has been spectacular it's coming
around look at you okay so now look this
whole team yeah I'm a believer I like
what's going on right now because it's
sustainable I think so if if you know
what the office if Mitch continues to
grow true Biscay is big if but you know
what I think you know what I'm really
here is what I hate about but I love up
in Chicago as a parent it's most of it
here's what I hate about being from
Chicago to Chicago fan mmm our media
does not want us to be happy with our
team and Chicago fans want to always
find a fault what are you talking about
Mitch too risky everybody's saying like
I don't know if he's the guy why did
Ryan pace move up what a mistake we saw
what happened against the Giants without
Mitch
mm-hm chase damages he's a great backup
our offense our coordinator our
everything would naggy Mitch delivers it
he's already taken the step Mitch's
running ability is what it makes it miss
what was it six touchdowns a baby I mean
we like to say as a system when we're
being hateful we're we're like well it's
naggy we got a great system anybody can
run it but then when you watched our
backup know you need it number to pick
to run that office well know this Jake
no matter how much you think that people
are being told they should not be happy
at least it's not New England where it's
ingrained in you as a New Englander that
you may not be happy about this
until you're completely unhappy yes
that's right so that that's what we have
used to have the Red Sox and Cubs in
common that's the curse we can hold on
to from Chicago fantastic okay so Jake
Johnson we play a game here called start
bench cut ok so we give you three
choices ok and you must start
one band cut one that is it okay here we
go start bench top with Jake Johnson be
quiet all right so you must start bench
and cut one of the follow you have the
music here okay Chris Farley we were
told you wanted to be with growing up
momentum on John Belushi Bill Murray
oh you're doing the tough deep come on
and that's really this is mean those are
three of my guys I know there's three
guys that's why we given you a wife to
give you a choice
well I think I would I got a start Chris
Farley I love that he when I was growing
up I love Belushi as a little guy
mmm-hmm I was born in 78 I think he died
in 81 and I remember the clippings it
was my first experience with seeing and
what a funny person how they could
affect people watching my family crying
I was like oh I'm just being funny but I
didn't fully grow up with it okay
Bill Murray was always very cool when I
was growing up very it's funny yes but
when I was a kid watching Farley jump
around and jump over till I was 10 years
old I exploded with tears so I got oh
just starting Farley I can't go wrong
you know I'm cutting Belushi okay
and I'm benching Murray just because
Murray's kicking in a really interesting
way as his career keeps going I like so
I'm just gonna was at metlife on Sunday
yes singing uh bear down he was he's
always good I love everything about him
all right next one if you could have one
thing happen within your lifetime which
would it be
bears winning the Super Bowl Cubs win
two more World Series and you're
nominated for an Oscar but you don't win
of course really good a rich I'm gonna
cut nominated for an Oscar attaboy
way to take one for the team I'm
actually gonna bench Cubs win two World
Series and I'm gonna start the Super
Bowl bears I love it
yeah good choices yeah he can't go wrong
all right next one for four Jake Johnson
start bench cut deep-dish pizza Italian
beef sandwich Chicago dog
ooh I'm going to I'm gonna cut the
Italian beef I love an Italian cutting
it if I gotta go this year I guess I'm
benching the hot dog love me a hot dog
love me at Chicago dogs I just had a
dish yeah I've just had a billion of
them in my life and they've just done a
number on it there's never a is there a
bad deep dish I can't there's just not
so if I'm gonna do it I want the deep
dish I'm not gonna be an old-school fat
boy I need the whole thing I'm not
getting a pitcher of beer I'm gonna have
two slices and B okay well I'm gonna put
it on the line here do you have a choice
of your deep-dish I mean is there it's
actually a place in Lincoln Park that's
not as famous called Bochy knows it's
like Al Pacino but with Abby but she
know what she knows and I went there
accidentally my dad lived by there when
I was in my 20s and I thought like oh
you don't get I don't need a pizza from
here
I just just blew me away so you that's a
deep fry it puts the deep that put it
makes so much it's so bad she that's so
good okay all right here's a last one
for you here okay Chicago dog condiment
no ketchup allowed currently mustard
peppers or onions mustard peppers onions
start bench cut uh got a start mustard
come on you just every ballgame you've
ever had all you would get was mustard
just they didn't give you the options
and now I'm not I don't like that you go
to a game now and they have like their
sections of condiments okay I'm gonna
cut Pepper's we're talking about hot
dogs and I'll bench onions onion you can
find their way back in I don't need them
to play if we're winning without onions
onions could work they're looking fine
their way you know six-man of the year
and could be the onion onions is it so
you're saying onions is what the Craig
Hodges of Congress but it's always it's
nice to have but you never needed for a
dish was that by the way is it what's
her name it you just said Nikki Simpkins
yeah and then you saute em now you got a
Derrick Rose Wow
pretty good dress see tell onions
there's a path yeah there's a path I'm
getting a game I love it
okay before I let you go did you did you
Jake Johnson meet Stan Lee did you get
me fortunately did not all what a bummer
it is a bummer
but I have you know obviously I cared
about Peter Parker as a kid but doing
press for this I've realized people care
about this universe in ways I can never
imagine we've done comic-con a couple
times it's serious business is serious
business because how many people are
gonna show up to the movie and think
it's not a cartoon right there's gonna
be some people who might do that yeah
but it's not even a crisis it's a comic
book yeah it's close but what I realized
about yeah about Stan Lee through this
was how his message was about inclusion
and how revolutionary Peter Parker was
when he first came up with it just a
Jewish kid in Queens who has superpowers
nowadays doesn't seem that crazy that he
could do it but then it was really wild
that that was a superhero and I never
got that until people kind of explained
how wild Peter Parker was because when I
grew up Peter Parker was just spider-man
so this movie are all characters in his
universe and it's now different people
exploding with those powers right but it
was pretty neat to have people say in
their opinion that was his original
message I'm like oh I kind of missed
that about Stan Lee I just thought he
was like a really creative guy who liked
this right but like oh there was a
deeper thing behind that guy in a way
that's been cool to learn that you have
you stopped at any moment I'm like oh my
god I just you know I just played Peter
Parker you know I mean it has kind of it
happened when I first got the job but
they didn't let me announce it for a
year and a half sauce constantly afraid
of being replaced by like one of those
guys who would win the Oscar one day
what and so my fear would die you know
it was everything was I've been
recording this for two-and-a-half years
you've been cultivating this caper yeah
we've been doing this that we write in
it and then you know we would record
then they would animate around that then
we do new drafts I've done every scene
in this movie probably 25 times this was
not a job where we popped in for three
or four record right you're in it right
so my fear was before was officially
announced like eight months ago at any
point you could get somebody else in
that booth so once I was announced
everything has gone fast
I think I'll sit back you're in and you
know be really excited when it is is all
done the movies out but it's been it's
been a dream job I love the car here we
go
spider-man into the spider verse in
theaters Friday December 14th your bears
are really good and and look like you're
set for a while yeah I think so this is
good I mean good I don't the you know
you got the the Packers are falling
apart they can't figure it out must be
long as sodas falling apart what is
happening they made such a mistake at
the quarterback position and Detroit's
Detroit seems like that head coach
should stick around as a defensive
coordinator and we're just walking
around the north having fun and then the
Golden Globe nomination go Incredibles
to you let me here here's your oh your
competition stiff man let's see the NFC
North Murray Ralph breaks the internet
and then you yeah take it home brother
yeah that'd be fun take Pixar out bro
take him right out you know it feels
like Matt nag he's running this one he's
our Phil Lord we all have our spots and
see what we can do in the north we got a
big game on Sunday please please wear a
visor to the Golden Globes if I did it
for Matt Nash or your dick of your
Dickus what's Gould school well I still
like about every big nationalized
televised game there's some guy out
there who does the Ditka dress code and
the camera always finds them but that
guy now and I'm 40 that guy keeps
getting younger so I'm like somebody's
passing on this tradition there's some
28 year old guy I barely saw Ditka I'm
like these kids now dressing him I'm
like you never even no idea but I love
that that's a Bears tradition that
hopefully goes on forever
at mr. Jake Johnson on Twitter come back
anytime I do better Congrats again go
check out spider-man into the
spider-verse in theaters Friday December
14th
Kyler's Murray he's up for the Heisman
Trophy he's the AP college football
player of the year from Oklahoma he's
joining us in our number three Chris
Brockman's news update and more here on
a rainy
Thursday in Los Angeles the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience